I know from this point our lives are
going to change and I knew it because
you see all the proof with your videos
we went for it we handed down out with
Suzanne and then we quit and then
started property full-time and you've
made a profit of how much in the last
three or four months
shy and Charlotte welcome to my house
okay so you're a dream of coming on
winners on a Wednesday did you think it
would happen this fast not at all it's
been on our goals list we did it when we
first joined and known to be here is
absolutely crazy great so how did you
guys meet and when did you decide you
wanted to get into property
um so we went about three years ago
about three years you all we used to
work together and it's just I wanted to
go on property since I was a kid and
we've always spoke about it I mean we
were both in full-time jobs and so I
have a legal background so I was you
know working my dream job technically
and fashion label for you wasn't it so
we were both grafting away and we wanted
to get into property saw your videos and
I remember seeing all these people on
winners on a Wednesday and thinking if
they can do it why can't we of course we
can so that's kind of where it went from
there and then I wanted to join the
Academy I remember seeing all your
videos that's when I'll message you on
LinkedIn said right this is for me I
want to join and our lives are going to
change and how many months ago was that
four months ago and since then you
joined the academy you've both quit your
jobs yeah we just handed that out
you've got lots of different experience
with different deals now development
rent to rent deal selling and you've
made a profit of how much in the last
three or four months 35k yeah
well congratulations thank you thank you
how did we first meet us so I I think
you've mentioned it before
um the the course that I came to last I
think I'm the first person that ever
joined the academy blind
I think I don't think you're the first
oh maybe maybe
what do you mean how blind was it what
happened so I'd never met you before in
my entire life yeah I hadn't been to any
courses we hadn't been to any events I
just think after using videos
and then that's when I messaged you on
LinkedIn and I was so surprised that you
responded but from there the whole way
you respond to everyone which is amazing
and then we got chit chatting about the
academy and then Chris called me and
then from there I was like yeah I think
you're the first person actually yeah
that's ever attended the academy without
like meeting me in person first having
an interview but you were just like on
the phone I want to do this yeah I spoke
to one of our training advisors went
through we went through your criteria
all on the phone and then you yeah you
registered for the academy and dropped a
lot of money was that it was out of the
blue literally was in Edison looking we
drive around looking at houses all the
time yeah and then schlich just turned
to me I said I'm gonna join and that's
12 000 pound investment how did you feel
about that shy I was just honestly it
was just a case of
yeah that's one thing that I was saying
because it was 12 000 pounds but at the
same time I kept saying to show I know
from this point our lives are going to
change and I knew it because you see all
the proof with your videos yeah and then
we went for it we handed our notices in
and then we quit and then started
property full time that's that's risky I
have to say like I would not advise that
to my folks watching this on on YouTube
don't watch a couple YouTube videos and
they go you know what you know what
forget it I'm I'm joining the academy
I'm quitting my job I'm because normally
it's come down to a one pound course
meet me and then think about it and then
we can slowly work towards getting to
that point and then obviously the
academy is like the top end mounting top
experience so you went from nothing to
unlimited mentoring coming down to my
house having all of the coaches access
to so much all of the contracts and
everything
um what happened then yeah if we went to
our first course so within like the
first month of course we were doing like
the online training yeah and then we
went to the first course which one was
it which was the first course Master
Class went to that one and we'd already
done the training so one of the mentors
said to me kind of have some deals ready
if you've got an A and then that's when
we had our first ever deal ready
um
yeah it was just such good energy we
loved it and then that was when we ended
up selling our first deal
so you sold your first deal on the first
day of the deal assembly Master Class
yeah that's incredible wow how much did
that bring you in two thousand dollars
two grand that was a five bed HMR yeah
five bed hm High spec very high spec
when you sold that and you saw the money
come in obviously I know it's the two
grand it's not a huge amount of money
but did that kind of give you the
confidence that this is doable this is
possible 100 I'm very optimistic as well
I think that's why we took that leap of
just leaving our jobs because we're very
big on if you want to achieve something
go for Force yeah and you'll achieve it
how's it going now then like this is now
fast forward what six months so that was
our first month so then three months on
from then so it's been four months as a
whole and how's it going well in terms
of with the deals we've sold about 35
000 pounds worth of deals damn she's
amazing it's like an annual salary right
there yeah exactly like this was I was
on I was on 21k last year
so to see going from 21k for the year to
35k in three months is yeah so and
that's just from deal selling yeah we've
got one essay as well yeah we've got RSA
as well but we also secured our essay at
the deal selling masterclass as well
because it's a JV with someone in the
academy that's the magic that's the
magic of the training program honestly
honestly it's been a major blessing so
your rent to rent yeah how um how did
you secure that so it was actually with
Chantelle on the academy so it's a JV so
she brought the opportunity to us and
said do you want a JV and we're in
Birmingham anyway so we were like 100
City Center we went to view it but it
was all secured kind of while we were
there anyway and yeah from there we just
kind of say oh profits are amazing how
much profit did it make this month 1 600
pound profit oh man again that's almost
a full-time salary 1 600 just this month
yeah
really good honestly and it's convenient
for us because where our office is it's
about a five minute drive yeah so did
you guys have an office now as well yes
we got office on Broad Street what's it
called Bayside Tower
High living Estates so you've got high
living Estates in Birmingham you've got
a little office that you rent the
highways Building
made it now you know you made it when
you got an office with your company name
on it yeah it is nice awesome how does
it feel like does it feel does it feel
crazy how successful you've become so
quickly it's a bit surreal I think the
biggest thing for me is I went from
watching your videos
at work every day to then it becoming a
day-to-day thing so the things that we
was learning about reading about we're
now doing every day and it's honestly
it's a major blessing well when we spoke
on the phone and I remember saying to
you so I just knew that Charlotte was
going to be extremely successful because
I think you knew it though didn't you
yeah you you weren't you weren't joining
the academy to mess around no you
weren't joining the academy saying I
hope this works cross my fingers you
were doing saying this is gonna work
this is what I'm gonna do the academy is
going to be a tool to help me get where
I'm going anyway but I'm doing this and
this is my mountain and I'm getting to
the top where did that where did that
kind of fire come from I think both of
us always naturally had it in us we
always wanted to live a lifestyle where
we were happy and comfortable and you
know like future children for ETC
generational wealth so that was kind of
always where we were at and then when we
kind of realized with property we could
take it there we had to take the risk it
was a no-brainer for us and then I think
one thing as well because we did quit
our jobs we had that hunger
that's what really pushed us was the
hunger for it what would you have done
if it hadn't worked or was that just not
an option not an option honestly I
always say failure is not an option and
if it doesn't work there's a reason it
hasn't worked analyze white hasn't
called a bit straight away when you saw
that first deal at the deal selling
masterclass now remember do you remember
the uh the training when you're on the
phone making calls on it yeah I was
recording yeah I was stood right behind
you listening yeah you don't even know
it but you were good on the phone and um
you know when you sold that first deal
did you have a plan of how you were
gonna like for instance when you do
something you need to have an investors
list you need to be compliant you need
the expertise to know how to sell you
need good deals like what was your game
plan and how did you go about building
such a successful deal sourcing company
I think it was the training where we
really realized okay we can Network here
whilst learning and then as soon as with
Robin with his deal we sold that we just
kind of thought right okay it's been
sold now what do we need to do because
we always wanted to look at the customer
Journey as well kind of the client
customer investor journey and so from
that point we just we approached people
I think I stood up at one point as well
and I was a bit cheeky and I was like
I've got two deals but I think that's
the thing that's amazing as well about
your courses is that you have the
opportunity to stand up and speak and
for people that you know they're a
little bit more shy and they don't want
to you just need to go for it because I
don't like standing up and speaking but
I did it leaving you said at the end as
well you had people queue you're not
waiting yeah
you mentioned the success that I'd gone
through and I joined the academy blind
there was a queue of people at the end
of that event waiting to get my contact
details you've also been selling not
you've not been selling houses you've
also been selling land
development opportunities big deals
right down to the smallest deals of dude
that just basic rent to rent where are
you finding all these deals like where
are they coming from honestly one thing
we always do is networking is a massive
thing for us so from messaging hundreds
of people on LinkedIn to going to
networking events reaching out to one
thing that you say as well is you never
know who around you who's got money to
invest so a lot of our connections as
well are from people who we've known for
years yeah they've got a plot available
now which is three acres asking prices
around three million and that's through
someone I've known for the past seven
years I would never have thought that
that's the position that was in so it's
so deal selling them to what you
literally just matchmaking so you're
fine you've got a friend who's got some
land he wants to sell it you're then
appraising the site looking at the deal
making sure it Stacks you're then
finding an investor and they're paying
you for the introduction
and then what happens if they pay you a
fee and then they see the land that come
out and they're like oh man this this is
not what I thought this sucks like how
does it expectations and stuff how does
that all work contractually so we kind
of still use the same basis as a rent to
rent deal so with 14 day period of
course we've landed slightly different
because things can take a lot longer
yeah I think we always try to make sure
that the investor is happy and I think
the important thing is yes there's a
contract there but you also need to be
very reasonable with so I think that's
one thing that we are begun to be
reasonable you know they come and see
the land if they're not happy they're in
their 14 days or anything like that it's
just it's fine you can walk away and
that means 40 days you're talking about
calling off periods so that if they pay
you money and then they see it and
they're like oh my gosh this is
atrocious that I like it they can get a
refund but at the same time it's I think
business is about Fair exchange isn't it
and it's about a win-win yeah so it's
about making having making sure your
contract is fair to them but fair to you
so where are your investors coming from
Mostly it's a mix
as I mentioned I think there's a lot of
platforms that I didn't realize were so
useful Facebook being one which is
amazing we just have investors just
messaging us do you have something in
Bristol do you have something in
Birmingham and then straight away add me
to your mailing list straight away we
always get that we go to networking
events we meet people even though
friends and family are like oh I want to
get involved in return
so now it's just a wide range a lot from
LinkedIn as well especially on the land
side of things LinkedIn honestly has
been very active on LinkedIn like very
active probably more active than I am I
feel like we've especially on the larger
scale things as well yeah that's where
the business owners are the land buyers
are Etc so for our target audience
linkedin's being the best platform in
regards to finding new investors
question how hard is it selling that
you're getting the deal over the line
because once you've got the deal you've
got the investor and you're on the phone
yeah is it do you have to really use
some serious sales skills or do you find
that investors are just absolutely
desperate for deals right and it's more
so based off the information you're
providing if you've got enough use for
information then you kind of don't
really have to do much talking it's a
case of you provide them the information
as long as they've got enough to go off
yeah and they'll make that decision ones
if you give them the information and
then they steal the deal so recently
there was an occasion where this almost
happened so we have a connection in
Coventry with an agency and we work
exclusively with them which is amazing
so any properties on company let they
literally just pass them over to us
straight away they're like they're yours
which is amazing
um and then we were sending some
information over to an investor who was
interested in a potential rent to sa in
Coventry he's obviously saw the video
and because it was City Center postcode
he then found it online and called the
agents wow but then the agents called
her straight away like oh is this your
client he's called us
that must have been so embarrassing for
him exactly so then we had to go back to
him and say look we have got an excuse
that's funny and that's the thing is it
shows the importance of having a good
relationship with the agent definitely
people can't do that when you've got a
good relationship with the agent and
also I assume as well sometimes you
might use non-disclosure agreements yeah
I think as well when you're selling a
deal one of the but I've personally
found when I'm selling the deal the
biggest thing that's helped me sell that
deal is my reputation when you build up
your reputation as a deal sorcerer with
me I can almost say to an investor I'm
not even going to give you the figures
I'm not even going to give you the city
where it is all I'm going to say is
you're going to be happy pay me the
money sign there and if you're not happy
I'll give you a refund in 14 days like
obviously I would never say that but my
point is firstly I'm going to listen to
what my investor has to say what are you
looking for what's your budget I'm going
to really understand what they're
looking for and then if I say to them I
got an opportunity damn I could I can
sell bespoke the all sorts and I can say
give me a grand I'll go find something
and if I find something in the next
month give me another two grand if I
don't I'll give you the grand back it's
it's when you've got a reputation it's
so easy I think one of the things I'm
seeing with you guys as a company is
because you're looking after your
investors yeah I've never heard anyone
say a bad thing about you guys I've
never heard all I've heard is good
things I've heard people say Oh What A
Deal of thumb I've joint mentioned with
them it's all been positive and I think
within the community within the academy
because people are seeing that even if
you've had things go wrong you've
refunded you've put things right yeah I
know you have my point is that you're
getting to a point now I think where
you're probably getting more investors
wanting to do deals with you than you've
even got deals yeah so talk to me about
code deal sourcing and how you're now in
the community helping people with code
deal sourcing talk to me about what that
is so code deal sourcing is where you
have um two companies so one will have
the investor and one will have the deal
and then you come together and you get
that sold so for example if you don't
have the investor to sell that deal to
but you've got an amazing deal you can
then collaborate together sell the deal
and then you spit the finders fee so
you've both benefited from it yeah and
we do this we have sometimes people come
to us because their investors might be
specifically looking for hmos and
they're like coming to me and go oh man
I've got a land opportunity but my
investors aren't looking for this so
they'll pass it to me I'll sell it yeah
we'll split the fee so what would you
say about coding your sourcing what
would be the advantages to you why would
you want somebody to bring deals to you
for you to sell it why would you not
find your own deals I think at the
moment for us our investor list is just
growing more and more each day and of
course we're based in Birmingham so we
have investors that want deals up north
or down south so of course we'll try our
best to get to viewings Etc but I think
cold deal sourcing's brilliant where for
example someone's not compliant they
find us a deal in Liverpool and we've
got an investor waiting for a deal in
Liverpool we collaborate together and
then we've both benefited amazingly from
it we've got some of us that they look
for deals Scottish border so it's the
thing where for us it's the best yeah
one of my pet hatches when people come
to me and they're like can you tell me
this deal and I'm like okay and then I
speak to my investors and then my
investors like yeah that sounds good but
then when I actually go to do a praise
the deal I'm looking at it I'm thinking
this isn't a deal yeah this is just a
house and there's actually nothing
special about it it's not below market
value it's not a good Roi it's it's just
not a deal and my advice would be if
anyone's wanting to bring deals to in
Deal sources for them to partner with
first thing is get good at finding deals
and then when you get rid of finding
deals there's plenty of deal sources
like you guys and Lewis and mount loads
of people that will help sell those
deals but first get good at finding the
deals and I think that's also why it's
great doing business with other people
on the academy that have also had the
training because then they're not
bringing you rubbish yeah they're
bringing you good stuff does that make
sense I think that's as well why there's
a lot of trust in the academy which is
amazing and I do think as well that is
why we sold our first deal so quickly
because naturally in the academy you
will trust each other you all want to
help I mean even with that first deal we
didn't just kind of sell it and say
there you go have fun you know we then
help Robin stage the rooms we went with
him on key collection day we took
pictures we made some experience out of
it which was really really nice what has
been the hardest point of being
full-time entrepreneurs
I think I had a wobble
yeah I think it was within the first
month so we'd sold the first deal and
then we would just kind of waiting to
get another gun and we were trying
really hard we're still figuring things
out as well still learning trying to be
full-time and then of course because we
quit our jobs I was getting stressed
thinking oh gosh hey we're going to pay
our bills did you have like savings
though yeah yeah yeah okay she had some
savings yeah we had savings we were okay
yeah but of course you always want to
elevate so we I was getting stressed I
had a little day I had a bit of a cry
and then it was funny because I had that
day and I had a bit of a cry and then
then that week we'd sold like three
Deals didn't we so it was like I had to
wobble for no reason but it happens I
think it is difficult when you just you
just take the risk yeah try and be a
business owner what's the plan now
moving forward like you're still quite
knew you've done 35 000 pounds profit
over the last few months which is
incredible you've got a rent to rent
deal that's bringing in very good income
insane by the time you finish the
academy which is about what seven months
time what's the plan I'd say
developments I think with me going into
property it was developments that got me
interested yeah and I think for us in
our dual sourcing is bringing in the
income for us to then be able to put
into the developments yeah and ideally
we want to get a larger scale
development yeah and even with people on
the academy like Lewis and Mal we work
really closely with them we're deals
selling as well and we've mentioned a JV
on a development you know either up
north and we're going to go visit their
projects up North so again it's another
example of how amazing the academy is to
connect and you could if we want to do a
large-scale development there's people
on the academy we know we can go to
straight away and they're like yeah
let's go yeah even some of our clients
even some of our clients are said if
we're open to a joint venture even then
they're open to that as well
what has been the highlight over since
you quit your jobs and went full-time
property has there been a moment where
you just like yes this is like it I'm so
glad that we did this I think maybe this
month yeah
four deals alongside with Lewis and
malbert we sell some as well but we sold
like four or five in the space of a day
or two wow so in how many hours 17 hours
how much did you make in those 17 hours
so it would have been like 12 000 yeah
12 Grand in 17 hours this month's been
the craziest month and that was a tough
week as well yeah that was having a
tough week that week yeah and it kind of
just happened
that what will be your biggest advice to
somebody that's new in their Journey
that's getting started in terms of like
practicalities or tips what would you
say is your best advice it's not going
to be smooth sailing and it's not going
to be easy this is one thing I think
when I was getting upset we said a lot
of the times if it was easy everyone
would be business owners but they're not
because unfortunately there's people
that are stuck in the nine to five so
100 I say it's not going to be smooth
it's not going to be easy but if you
keep pushing step system 100 like
winners on a Wednesday is proof that it
works yeah we're here now because it's
proof that it works yeah I think
resilience is the biggest thing and also
education that's why they need to come
to you to be educated I appreciate that
what's your experience been like on the
academy going on the courses and stuff I
know I know the Network's been amazing
but how's it how would you summarize it
energetic and just so positive like it's
just the whole Vibes of when you are on
the courses and you're with the people
everyone has that energy you can do it
yeah and it's funny because I think a
lot of people they do think oh I can't
do it well you come there and you just
straight away you leave and you think I
can do this
[Music]
yeah I think belief is important as well
because if you believe something you'll
find the evidence to back it up yeah and
if you're watching winners on a
Wednesday for instance thinking oh well
what's my you know you might go oh well
they already had money or they had a
good job their parents help them this
and you if you don't believe you can do
it you'll desperately try and find
something to back up your belief whereas
if you think actually you know what I
believe I can do this then you'll watch
the videos and it will massively Propel
your motivation the massive thing with
us we're everything we talk about we
want to achieve it's never or would love
to do this it's when everything's about
when it happens yeah everything that we
want to achieve we know we can do yeah
you I say if and he's like no no when
correct you know even with Windows on a
Wednesday that's one of the things
that's on our goals list for this year
yeah let's take it off and it's honest I
can't believe we've kicked it off so
soon as well you didn't Amaze it and
listen I'm sure we'll do a part two in
another year where you've got a budget
developments and stuff and we'll follow
your journey you know I just want to say
massive well done and you guys are a
great partnership you're a massive asset
to the academy and I'm really proud of
what you've done and excited to see you
continue to progress and thank you for
the academy and the training it's been
brilliant I appreciate that
foreign